and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a bum
tonight's review avatar I see spoilers
there's this bald boy who can control
the wind oops wrong avatar oh my god
this is also the greatest movie I've
ever seen in my night things this guy
who's in the future and he has lost my
legs once
oh wait in here so they send them to a
planet filled with blue people Ethernet
little Smurfs
these guys are pouring in huge Garfield
so the business people are like we have
to move these Murphy cash because
they're standing on top of this rock
this with like a bajillion dollars and
the military is like stuff that's like
my hipster so this guy with no legs is
put inside a smurfy Kent's body and it
has to convince the other boots Murphy
can't believe I know what that's like
all the time talking urine at a
children's playground Whitehead I said
geez so he meets up with the theme is
Murphy can't please a daughter of a king
and a female spiritual leader well one
of them I did and she's also betrothed
to this other guy yeah he's dead to most
people who are betrothed at the
beginning of movies are often dinner
that's how most Disney movies work I
mean not Disney movies work so they kind
of know let's get to learn the ways of
these smurfy tats what's up big bad
military
I love with the big bad corporation want
to tear the village down why who do you
think you are some kind of scientist yes
you think we pay you millions of dollars
to tell the truth yes and you think that
because you haven't really abandoned
years of loyal experience that we're
going to listen to you yeah well we're
not play because we're not bidding bad
military a loser big bad corporation
that makes no sense
so the tyrant noelites goes back to the
smurfy camp avi and get all of the other
smurfy cats together so that big bad
military come in to wipe them all out
with a machine gun giant giant robots
like death machines please okay because
the smurfy kids have bows and arrows and
they also use all these other animals to
destroy them because if there's anything
we've learned in the past is that
mankind is no good at destroying other
species we sucked at it I mean is you
see return the Jedi we came it went
badly watts and the tyrant fire
destroyed my teddy bears support our
troops against Murphy cats and teddy
bears
they are deadly so that's where we can
send all the humans back to their planet
and the guy with no legs officially
becomes a smurfy can't himself I know we
spend like a smurfy get trapped in a
man's body
don't be on and the morning the story is
anything that is human there's a and
anything there's not human is not even
pretty so I really like Fern Gully
focus into Celeste Empire Dances with
Wolves every turn somehow original movie
I've ever seen in my life I mean that
James Cameron is a genius
he took an idea that often make horrible
children's films and turn into a
million-dollar epic I want to see me
make some of my favorite children's
classics the Tom and Jerry movie must be
Rito's beneath Green baboon
this is Jerry Busey well can you at
least help me buy a booze movie ends or
are you afraid my yearning a profit
children playground too
you